former Washington Post writer Paul
Hendrickson tells the story of the civil
rights struggle in the u.s. from the
perspective of white opposition in Sons
of Mississippi this talk from the pen
humanities forum in Philadelphia is 40
minutes okay well hello I'm Randy
steiner and i'd like to welcome you
tonight to the pen humanities forum at
the university of pennsylvania 2002 2003
has been the humanities forms year of
the book an exploration of an object the
book that we in academia tend to take
for granted but after a year of
listening to publishers and media
experts and historians and book at
artists and librarians we found that
virtually everything we thought we knew
about the book is up for grabs at the
moment complicated by the new
technologies of communication that are
springing up all around us but one thing
has not changed and that is the crucial
importance of deeply researched
eloquently expressed ideas a good book
can change the world tonight we are
privileged to attend the launch of a
very good book indeed the Magisterial
achievement of paul hendrickson's sons
of mississippi the pen humanities forum
is delighted to join with its
co-sponsors Alfred a Knopf publishers
Kelly writers house and the Creative
Writing Program of the University of
Pennsylvania in celebrating the
appearance of this extraordinary for
scattered around the room I see Paul's
colleagues students family and friends
you already know more about Paul then I
can say in this short introduction but
here are some salient facts for you Paul
was educated in the south and has
degrees from st. Louis University and
that place that people sometimes
confused with Penn Pennsylvania State
University
for over 12 20 years Paul was a
prize-winning feature writer for The
Washington Post but left the post to
teach nonfiction writing here and he is
good students line up to get into his
courses and they stay in touch with him
for years after they finished the course
Paul is the author of course of other
books seminary looking for the light
which was a finalist for the national
book critics circle award and the much
honored book on Robert McNamara the
living and the dead now Paul has given
us this new work sons of Mississippi if
you know Paul you'll recognize him on
every page he tells us that quote the
idea for this book came on februari
nineteenth nineteen ninety-five while I
was standing in black oak books in
berkeley california paging through an
outside sized text of black-and-white
images entitled powerful days the civil
rights photography of charles floor you
have to know first that paul loves
photography if you visit him at home he
pulls out one book after another from
his shells pointing to this image in
that image and that image he's these
worlds in a picture and in sons of
mississippi he brings one of those
worlds to life turning a shocking image
in a photography book into a vast
panorama of southern racism and you see
the image in question here on the podium
you can hear the wonder of that
expansion of picture into world all
through sons of mississippi for example
when paul describes what went through
his mind when he finally tracked down
one of the figures in the photo he came
out of the lake house and it was as if
ink on a flat surface had come to life
sticking out it's thickened paw but of
course loving photography is not really
the point Paul brings this particular
picture to life as an object lesson in
awareness in the need to notice the book
is all about taking note imagining the
full picture however complex are
unresolvable it turns out to be and why
Paul tells us the name of the bookstore
and the book of photos where he saw this
picture and the precise date he was
struck by it and the fact that it was
outsized and that it's images were black
and white we don't have to know all that
but once we do we have a certain stake
in the moment the attention this book
pays to its subjects creates our stake
in their terrible history Sons of
Mississippi is a demonstration of how to
look at the world so as to give
everything everyone in it it's due
because once we do that it becomes
impossible to write things or people off
dismiss them feel unconnected to them
Paul gives the grinning racists in the
picture history's strengths misfortunes
not that we should forgive them on that
account not ever but understanding
requires the full picture otherwise a
person can turn into a target for a
baseball bat in a Mississippi Sheriff's
pause Paul says I can't precisely say
what it was about the image that so took
hold of me it had an overwhelming
storytelling clarity and simultaneous
confusion that openness to confusion
that deep curiosity and attention toward
other people go by the name of
generosity or maybe humanity they are
Paul's great gift and the great lesson
of his book please welcome Paul
Henderson
I don't deserve an introduction that
eloquent in just a moment I'll come back
to saying something about Wendy Steiner
thank you very much thank every one of
you for coming tonight the lights a
little bad up here so i think i may have
to hold what I'm going to say like this
but I think I'll make it Thank You Wendy
I have said at the end of other books
that there is a real sense in which each
one is only a record of those who
believed in it so before I talk about
sons of Mississippi I would like to take
a few minutes to pay public tribute to
some of those who have believed in it
crucially first my family seal Matt John
who are all here who put up with the
years of anxiety and only occasionally
asked about its progress they have
always been my true secret weapon in the
struggle to write books they have borne
more costs than I would care to say
yesterday morning downstairs in my
bathrobe looking at six column headlines
and pillars of fire I asked seal if we
should even have this event she is a
wiser person than I am she said yes
perhaps tonight can be a moment of
distraction from what is so terribly on
our minds Jonathan Segal a senior editor
and vice president and Alfred a Knopf he
rode the train down this afternoon from
Manhattan and he has to go back on a
late train tonight because of
commitments tomorrow an editor's life
John and I have been together through 23
years and for non-fiction books and a
lot of dreaming and a little bit of what
we allow ourselves to think of as
success it is the rarest thing I know in
the profit driven and often revolving
door
old of commercial book publishing to
have such a relationship and at a place
like konov no less this is a man who has
an incredible passion for both books and
ideas and his loyalty toward his riders
is something that leaves my imagination
a little blank already John and I are
dreaming and scheming toward the next
collaboration also in this room I need
quickly to mention Wendy Steiner her
gracious introduction of course she is
the director of the pen humanities forum
in this the year of the book it I I feel
I owe her once again a great debt she is
the reason I'm at the University of
Pennsylvania she was chairman of the
English department I was at the
washington post i wrote her a too long a
letter i think it's spilled over to the
second page she um she had Lisa knew who
was the undergraduate chairman who and
who is now at Harvard call me up and
Lisa said listen we got your letter we'd
like to pursue this wendy is a public
intellectual she's a writer in her soul
and I think she understood that it would
might be worth giving someone like me a
chance I would mention Gregg Janu kyun
who is my dear dear close friend on the
faculty the head of creative writing
here a friend I was fortunate enough to
find in middle age something rare and
former colleagues from the staff of the
Washington Post who made the trip here
this evening I am very grateful as I am
to my colleagues at the Kelly writers
house and in the English department at
Penn I I see half a dozen of you at
least sprinkled throughout the room I'm
so grateful this English department this
writers house a place where I have
landed so happily and luckily at this
relatively late point in my working life
again how rare that an ink-stained
wretch from the groves of newspaper dhum
could leave one world-class institution
and end up at another I need to mention
all of the people who helped to plan
this event most especially Jennifer
Conway and Catherine Olson at the forum
dotting every I crossing every T and
doing it so gracefully and that goes
also for Michelle summers of konov
publicity who has been working on this
kind of marathon book promotion tour
that we're on they are here tonight
you're going to hear some music later
and I promise you it will be sublime and
whatever words that I say will pale
compared to the live jazz you will hear
in a bit finally and in a sense most
importantly my students current
non-fiction writing students former
non-fiction writing students I have
tried to keep from balling many times
just from the pleasure and privilege of
being able to be with you in those upper
floor rooms at the Kelly writers house
you never want to believe it when I say
that you give me back far more that I
can ever impart to you it's your
earnestness your doubt your questing
your occasional brassiness it puts me in
touch with how I was so long ago only I
never had anything close to your
giftedness so I know it is a little
fanciful and you will forgive me but I
think of all of you and others I didn't
get a chance to mention such as
sisters-in-law and brothers-in-law and
neighbors and ordinary readers as
forming and constituting a kind of
borderless shadow community of
literature a network of support that
permitted an angsty writer to get it
done I think what each of us have in
common here tonight is a love for the
word in the beginning was the word as it
says in a book I once knew pretty well
in a former life this book I would like
to talk about it for the next 20 minutes
or so and then read two brief passages
and then maybe there will be some
questions I have always thought books
mysteriously find us rather than we them
this is a book about race and racism
although not primarily about black
people and their long struggle during
the years of civil rights and afterward
rather it's a book about white people
which is the color I am and about some
of those who can rightly be called
oppressors and about the legacy of
bigotry and fear and yes eight that pass
from one generation to the next it's a
book about the Ark of sorrow that
defines us as Americans more than any
other sorrow in a sense it's an entire
book about a single black and white
photograph what I can tell you is the
story of what happened and Wendy Steiner
already alluded to it beautifully I was
standing one night in a West Coast
bookstore in berkeley california and i
know that it was februari nineteen
nineteen ninety-five because I wrote it
in my journal when I'm on the road
generally I don't go to bars I go to
bookstores to cool out in the evening
after an exhausting day Bowl day and so
I was simply cooling outstanding at the
photography table at black oak books I
was just then finishing up another book
that had consumed me on and off for a
decade maybe something was
psychologically lifting that night I
don't know what I saw was this
photograph and I know you can't see it
all it appeared this way in its original
form in Life Magazine in
62 that's not where I saw it that night
I saw it in an anthology of civil rights
photograph photography by a gifted and
brave photo journalist named Charles
Moore who had worked for Life magazine
during the most brutal days of the civil
rights movement this was an anthology of
his work and it was entitled powerful
days I was idly paging through in a
sense trying to find my life after a
hard day's work and there on page 55 was
a picture that stopped me in my tracks
it was a photograph of seven southern
cops dressed up standing in a grove of
Elms and oaks and catalpa trees at
Oxford Mississippi on the campus of a
place known lovingly in the south as Ole
Miss the University of Mississippi the
figure in the middle of the frame was
biting off the tip of his cigarette was
pulsing the air with a stick that looked
tapered like a baseball bat the caption
of this photo said surrounded by his
cohort a law officer takes a practice
swing with a billy club I looked at it
and felt a kind of terror there were no
names no details of who these men were
they were Mississippi sheriffs and they
had gathered along with a swelling mob
of others along with their pride fulness
and paranoia and potentially lethal
rages to do what they could to keep
another American and fellow
Mississippian a black man named james
meredith from forcibly integrating with
federal troops and US Marshals the halls
and grounds of their sacrosanct
all-white State University this was
late-september 1962 there was just
something about the angles of cigarettes
and middle-aged men in white shirts and
ties and an armband that almost could
have
in a tourniquet something about a
strange-looking priest he had a club and
his profane deacons they were laughing
so nastily semi circled around an altar
or maybe it was the lid of a gleaming
coffin actually it was the barely
visible hood of a squad car as they
readied for their satanic rites I had
nothing but a black and white rectangle
in my hand 40 years old but something
dropped out got born I think I wanted
urgently to know not that I understood
it as such how did these white
Southerners these seven phases of deep
south apartheid get to be this way and
how did it all end or how is it still
going on and was there no eventual shame
here and what happened to their progeny
especially their progeny and was it all
just any luck tible to state it another
way where did the hatred and the sorrow
go that flowed out of this moment and
out of a lot of other moments like it in
seven particular lives that didn't get
captured by a camera and reproduced on a
photosensitive surface and then printed
across two pages in a national magazine
that back then possessed a kind of
religious communicative power in America
how did a gene of intolerance and racial
fear mutate as it passed sinuously
through time and family blood streams
even now after all these years of
looking at it examining it carrying it
back and forth I can't precisely define
what it was about the image that so took
hold of me and of course it was John
Segal several months after I had first
seen the photograph and was still
galvanized and got up the nerve to show
it to him who told me what I was trying
to do we were standing in my kitchen in
Takoma Park Maryland the night before we
had gone to see the Orioles play the
Yankees in Camden Yards in Baltimore
John who has never been to Mississippi
looked at it
moved his head from side to side drew in
his breath and said legacies the
direction you're trying to travel Paul
is this way so many stories mysteries
interconnected lives curling outward
from some faces under trees the search
turned out to be a series of outward
rippling concentric circles it was the
pebble dropped in the unquiet pool those
lives the parables there in expanded
exponentially all I had to do was follow
there was never enough time there were
constant surprises redemptive ones
bracing ones depressing ones the
research and writing spread across five
years I made somewhere in the vicinity
of 35 reporting trips to Mississippi and
to California and Texas and other places
in between a storytelling universe had
opened magically the search started with
what I could see inside the four edges
of the photograph two of the sheriff's
were alive when I began including the
lawman in the middle biting off the tip
of his filterless Lucky Strike his name
was billy farrell william t farrell and
he had been the head lawman of Natchez
Mississippi for 24 years a figure as
powerful as an unholy Pope in his own
jurisdiction I caught billy farrell when
he was long retired and in the last year
and a half of his life a seeming affable
rationalizing old man sitting on a dock
of a murky lake with psoriasis as he was
even then beginning to die his lingering
death of cancer and heart disease the
struggle was always to try to see them
as human beings to try to reconstruct
their lives not as bigoted cardboard
cutouts but as three-dimensional fathers
husbands law enforcers retirees who had
lived and strutted their hour of a
hauling Mississippi misdeeds man's
inhumanity to man how could I have known
standing in that Berkeley bookstore in
1995 that the son of billy farrell was
right then and still is the present-day
sheriff of Natchez Mississippi and not
only that but was a rising national
figure among all the sheriffs in America
right now that son william t farrell the
second whom everyone in mississippi
refers to as tommy is finishing up is
your long reign as president of the
National sheriffs Association he got
installed in a big ceremony last June in
Tulsa I was there his ego lit the room
he is a very complicated man he is he is
an inheritor it's a leap of faith it's a
mystery you just go if you go it'll
happen is what I am always telling my
writing students in nonfiction you have
this old buried inert thing in your hand
and you let it do with you what it will
what you are hoping for and can never
quite explained not least to yourself is
a kind of journalistic luck based on
terrible desire how could I have known
the first time I ever saw the image that
Tommy's son william t farrell the third
whom everybody refers to as ty would be
chasing illegal aliens on the us-mexico
border he's the feral so far from home
the one in the family of law enforcers
who so often seems close to tears whose
particular field of law enforcement is
apprehending desperate people trying to
get to the other side of a tantalizing
dream ty farrell works for the u.s.
Border Patrol he is very skilled at it
he's pretty compassionate at it he's a
short blocky man with fair features and
a moon ish face and this strange
propensity to cry at almost anything
there are probably a lot of ways to
think about the riddle of his story but
one of them is that a likeable and
palpably conflicted grandson has picked
up his family's whole burdened history
with race and carried it about a
thousand miles westward into a 21st
century setting where the colors of
oppression have a more brownish cast a
bad of hate bristle din the afternoon
sun of sep tember 1962 and two
generations and forty years onward I
traced legacies and tensions to santa
teresa new mexico in the life of a 35
year old employee of the department of
justice who is the cop by any other name
a feral by any other disguise or
temporary domicile driven haunted you
could say by the beliefs and deeds of
forebears all of it was sitting there
invisibly on his brawny shoulders I was
one standing with Ty Farrell at a fence
line in rural New Mexico separating
Mexico from the United States on this
side of the fence desert silence on this
side the tantalizing dream America over
there 25 yards off through the fence the
hovels the cater walling of a place
called Rancho and APRA we were standing
against the fence looking through he
didn't seem like a cop he didn't seem
like a feral but that was illusion he
was speaking softly almost to himself it
just goes on like this all the time I've
come out here to listen to it he said
pause they don't have toothbrushes over
there we've asked pause they burn tires
for their heat and light pause no
medicine over there pause no sewage no
electricity no running water pause I
don't understand it
would think with two countries so close
together one would pull the other up
somebody can be born right over there
and somebody else born right over here
and living their lives so close and I
said but isn't that Mississippi same
injustice the offspring of a man in the
center of a photograph turned away from
the fence he was looking directly at me
yeah I guess you could say that come to
think he said I don't know that I ever
thought of it in those same terms until
just now but yeah okay there is
something else I would like to tell you
i think the finding of a book the
seizing of it in your imagination loops
around in ways that cannot be rationally
parsed I realize now that standing in
that bookstore almost eight years ago as
I am speaking to you now there were many
other things working in my psyche even
autobiographical tensions it took a lot
of years and a lot of reporting and a
lot of thinking and a lot of traveling
to begin to understand it I do not wish
to speak here tonight autobiographically
not primarily and yet I think one of the
things I was trying to engage in this
book was a very hard question that might
be asked in this way aren't all of us
who are white in America in the frame to
unseen yet present may be standing way
off to the side but there somewhere in
the ring of batterers maybe even trying
on at least for a moment our only r or
sneer just to see how it fits at the
beginning of this talk I spoke about the
word and alluded to a book I once knew
pretty well I used to be a student for
the Catholic missionary priesthood it
marked me in indelible ways I'm grateful
for the experience and I'm still trying
to work it out of me I was a 14 year old
chicago boy who got on an illinois
central train at the michigan avenue
depot in chicago in the fall of nineteen
d 8 and wrote it to the deep south to a
place called holy trinity Alabama I
stayed seven years in religious life
until I was 21 until nineteen sixty-five
I got off the train that morning in
Columbus Georgia and there in the
terminal were two water fountains side
by side one said why don't the other
said colored only that was a rude moment
in my sheltered Midwestern Catholic
consciousness the world felt Pacific in
1958 the civil rights movement was just
opening we were behind cloistered
cloistered seminary walls but we could
hear the cracking sound beyond those
walls so I was an adolescent and then
nominally an adult in the mysterious
fragrant overhanging south and all these
years later I found my way back to it in
a story I think all of it loops around
so is their racial hope in Mississippi
in America for the 21st century it's too
broad a question I think the answer is a
qualified redemptive yes and an equally
qualified dispiriting no I think of it
as fragile hope the answer is
provisional it's by stutters and starts
it's a step ahead and a half a step of
falling backwards the story of all of
our lives what I found in Mississippi
were blades of hope what I found was
what seemed too often a nation of
strangers you have to water those blades
of hope let the Sun get on them breathe
toward and over them lovingly they are
so susceptible to trampling and quick
loss every blade of grass has its angel
that bends over it and whispers grow
grow it says somewhere in the Talmud i
am not a seer I do not have answers I
was always the infiltrator the visitor
the outsider I traveled to the lush
blistered paradise and place of Sorrows
called Mississippi and tried to under
stand at one point in the book I say
this in Mississippi nothing ever changes
and everything always changes and
sometimes it seems as if God put
Mississippi on earth purely for our
moral and confounding contemplation I
would like to read very briefly very
briefly to brief sections from this book
the first one is pretty hard pretty
graphic it concerns a man named Douglas
MacArthur cotton an african-american who
worked for snick the student the Student
Nonviolent Coordinating Committee
assigned to greenwood in the heart of
the delta which is where one of my
sheriff's was Sheriff everybody in the
movement knows him as Mac cotton he's in
his middle 60s now he lives far back in
a rural county in the woods his story is
not particularly unusual it's incredibly
heroic and not that unusual because it
was local people local African Americans
who put their bodies on the line who won
this war he was arrested on the
courthouse steps by one of my sheriff's
he had a five minute trial they
sentenced him to four months of hard
labor at the county farm they took him
that afternoon at five o'clock in a bus
with black grading out to the edge of
town and put him in those striped
pajamas and his crime was that he was
trying to take his fellow African
Americans from Greenwood to the
courthouse to register so I went to see
him and what I'm going to read you is
verified by various affidavits
it's something about the parable of the
wheel inside the wheel and the long
chain of moral consequence at the county
work farm the prisoners were put in
striped uniforms and made to cut
roadside grass with Kaiser blades if you
wanted to go to the bathroom you told
the Sarge taking a leak here shot one
day out in the fields the shot cocked
and pointed a pistol at Matt cotton he
did this because the prisoner had asked
the guard to call him by his name and
not by the word [ __ ] everybody stopped
working the moment defused but afterward
the prisoner and some of his fellow
prisoners went on a hunger strike and
for this they were sent to the
Mississippi State Penitentiary at
Parchman things had notched themselves
up now for Parchman it was all you ever
had to say during the civil rights era
Parchman was the prison hellhole of the
south parchman farms has been grieved
into song and poetry by generations of
mississippi blues men it sits on highway
49 w in the middle of the Delta about an
hour's drive north west of Greenwood for
most of the 20th century inmates at
parchment chiefly did one thing in
daylight work the farms thousands of
acres of crops notably cotton under the
gun and bull whip the whip was known by
some as black Annie at Parchman the
sassy prisoner from Greenwood with a
generals name began to suffer a drip
from his penis to get sores on his
tongue on his gums and in his throat Mac
cotton told a guard about this and an
answer to a question he made the mistake
of saying yes instead of yes sir for
this he got the hot box you goddamn
[ __ ] shut up that goddamn racket I'll
throw your ass in the sweatbox the guard
said to the others according to an
affidavit later filed sometimes it
parchment the guards would take you to
the box naked jerk
can you buy your penis in the box the
only air came from a crack under the
door several days later back in his cell
the prisoner who supposedly gotten his
mind right eight with his fingers from a
face bowl at one point there were 14 men
in one cell one was trying to sleep
against the toilet mac cotton had the
unreasonableness to ask for someone
else's food when that inmate said he had
no appetite the guards heard about this
and the next day they served cotton 3
butter beans and a piece of crust about
the size of a paradise he told them to
take those crumbs away he didn't need
them and for this insolence he got put
on the bars getting put on the bars in
Mississippi meant that the guards made
you stand on your toes while they roped
you by your wrists to the top bar of
your cell I peed and [ __ ] it out all
over myself cotton is saying we are in
his living room we have not met before I
have brought with me a sheaf of the
classified papers and affidavits and
other things that I have obtained from
civil rights archives and government
files Mac cotton seems uninterested in
looking at any of these papers at least
for now he has placed them facedown on
the coffee table aligned their edges in
a neat stack I think about this a lot he
says he means parchment Penitentiary in
1963 and of his hanging on the bars and
of the peeing and [ __ ] out all over
himself in front of his fellow freedom
workers I think what God did for me I
was just kind of floating through the
air after a time after a while all of it
was taken away I imagine about after
eight hours I was removed from the pain
of it his wife Mamie is typing on a
computer and listening in grandchildren
are playing in another
why aren't you riled up why should I be
riled up he answers but they were
invading your rights it feels ludicrous
phrasing it so weakly my whole existence
was illegal in their eyes he answers
that goes on for a few more pages Matt
cotton is a very minor character in this
story except he's very major and I just
wanted to give a feeling of what African
Americans were up against in our own
country just one generation ago and I
will conclude with this and this is
about 60 pages ahead of what I just read
to you it's the other side I think the
other side is important to think about
but in every dark there are particles of
light Mississippi of an early morning
before the heat is up can lie proud on
the mind like linen on your arm driving
through the deep summer green of the
Natchez Trace what you are struck by
most of all is the beauty not all white
southerners are overweight bigots and
not all rural Mississippi blacks are
ennoble by their poverty that is ever
the temptation in an outsider's I the
great beauty seems to slip up on you
unawares in parts of lower and eastern
and northeastern Mississippi the earth
turns to a deep orange almost read in
vivid contrast to the dark alluvial
riches of the Delta on the trace one of
America's oldest roads which cuts the
diagonal through the state the Cardinals
and Jays will be flitting out beyond
your car hood as if to guide you enchant
you the light on this road today seems
clear as Jen you've gone ten miles and
have yet to see another car last night I
side your motel the air felt so moist
and heavy and mysterious it was early
dark and you were speaking to your
family you stood at a payphone bolted to
a utility pole as the blackness netted
down over you in a kind of softening
cone you looked down and saw the cover
of your notebook starting to coat with
wetness the scent of something perfumed
was coming up Jasmine down the street
porches glowed with lamps then this
morning at dawn cruising on a four lane
with the window open the air so
freshening on your face you looked over
and saw Holsteins and a pasture stolid
as boulders missed curling around their
ankles in Mississippi just the white
lettered names on blurring green road
signs seem invested with something rich
and musical and seductive boga chido
nashoba Oklahoma these are Choctaw names
they're supposed to be a spot somewhere
in this state called hot coffee although
it doesn't seem to be on any maps
there's another spot called Panther burn
you've been there there's a place called
increase it never has it's so puzzling
that a land of such charm and physical
beauty a place of such natural grace and
disposition to kindness could have so
appalling a history standing once in the
old capital museum in downtown Jackson
not hating this state but taken with it
at least for now you saw this printed on
a small sign card I can love Mississippi
because of the beauty of the countryside
and the old traditions of family
affection and for such small things as
flowers bursting in spring and the way
you can see for miles from a ridge in
winter why should a Negro be forced to
leave such things because of fear no not
anymore do you know who said that
james Meredith thank you very much
Paul Hendrickson teaches non-fiction
writing at the University of
Pennsylvania sons of Mississippi a story
of race and its legacy is published by
Knopf a division of Random House visit
Random House calm / Knopf for more
information